how's it going everybody it's Warren and
in today's video I'm going to talk about
something that could quite possibly be
the most important easter egg in
avengers endgame it's important not to
Avengers in game but to the whole entire
future of the MCU specifically in
regards to Marvel introducing the
multiverse into the MCU and specifically
in regards to a new character entering
the MCU so I'll talk about this Easter
Egg and why it's so important to the
future of the MCU in this video but
first a quick reminder about my giveaway
at the 450,000 subscriber mark I will be
picking three winners and each one will
get to choose one item from the Marvel
Legends series collection I'll talk more
about it at the end but be sure to
subscribe to my channel so you can enter
so there were a few characters kind of
hinted at in Avengers in game but not
dropped by name name war was one when
they mentioned an underwater earthquake
but this Easter Egg was actually
mentioned by name when Steve Rogers and
Tony Stark go back in time to the 1970s
to get the tesseract Steve actually sees
Peggy Carter through a window in her
office now most people were paying
attention to how Steve was reacting but
if you listen to what Peggy Carter was
saying she mentions an agent Braddock
who hasn't checked in now some of you
may be familiar with the name Brian
Braddock dent for those of you who
aren't this is Captain Britain Marvel
Studios as President Kevin Feige has
mentioned several times that he would
like to introduce Captain Britain into
the MCU and it seems like this Easter
Egg could be that first step now this
was already pretty exciting news when
they named dropped Braddock in Avengers
in game but then we got the second
trailer for spider-man far from home and
they mentioned the multiverse Captain
Britain is directly connected with the
multiverse Captain Britain is a part of
the Captain Britain Corps which is
essentially a team of superheroes
consisting of alternate versions of
Captain Britain they're all essentially
the same hero they just come from an
alternate reality and the main job of
the Captain Britain Court is to guard
the multiverse each member of the
Captain Britain Corps guards their own
reality so in Avengers in game there's
an Easter Egg for a Braddock and then a
few weeks later Marvel drops the second
spider-man far from home trailer which
they introduced the multiverse in now
Marvel doesn't really name drop without
it meaning something and in the comics
Brian Braddock aka Captain Britain and
Peter Parker are roommates at one point
in time and I'm not saying that Captain
Britain is going to show up in
spider-man fire from home but there are
a lot of connections here and it has
been said that the multiverse is the
future of the MCU so Kevin Feige has
stated that they've discussed Captain
Britain before and then we hear the name
Braddock and Avengers endgame and now
the multiverse has been mentioned in
spider-man far from home so it seems
like they're setting it up for Captain
Britain to enter the MCU
but another main point of this Easter
Egg and the future of the MCU with the
introduction of Brian Braddock is his
sister his sister is Betsy Braddock
otherwise known as the mutant psylocke
that's right his sister is a mutant
right from the x-men comics in fact
Psylocke has been in the Fox x-men
movies so this could be a connection to
introducing the x-men into the MCU as
well now it's important to note that the
name was dropped in the 1970s and if
Marvel isn't going to adjust the time
line there most likely referring to
James Braddock James is the father of
Brian and Betsy and was also a part of
the Captain Britain Court at one point
in time in the comics James ends up
working with shield so this could be who
they're referring to when they mention
agent Braddock now during the scene
agent Carter is talking with somebody
about a supernatural phenomena and they
say that it was not lightning and that
agent Braddock has not checked in yet
well in the comics James dies in what is
made to look like an accident in a lab
but it was actually somebody murdering
him so perhaps this Easter Egg is a
reference to James dying and that it's
made to look like Lightning did it
because right after James dies in the
comics is when his son ryan braddock
gets his powers and becomes Captain
Britain the introduction of Captain
Britain to the MC would open up a ton of
possibilities for the future of the MCU
obviously like I just said he's
connected directly with the multiverse
they could introduce the Captain Britain
Corps and they could introduce his
sister who is a mutant and they could
start to introduce the x-men into the
MCU and this opens it up for other
characters to enter the MCU as well such
as Black Knight who was rumored to
supposed to be in Avengers in game so
let me know what you think about this
Easter egg in Avengers in game with
Marvel drop in the
braddock remember Marvel normally does
not name drop unless it mean something
and with a lot of connections to the
multiverse and spider-man it seems like
we maybe seen Captain Britain into the
MCU soon but let me know your thoughts
on this video in the comments down below
and again another reminder about my
giveaway when I hit 450,000 subscribers
I will be picking three winners and each
will get to choose one item from the
Marvel Legends series collection and
then at five hundred thousand
subscribers half a million I'll be doing
a huge giveaway that I will announce
soon I'll also be doing some giveaways
on Instagram and Twitter soon if you
want to follow me on there also if you
enjoy other non Marvel related movies
and shows you can check out the other
channel I started called cosmic culture
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof you said it'd cost you
everything while crying like a baby